what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have alex
from playing with fire um he is a men's
dating coach
yeah thank you for having me on much
appreciated
yeah thanks for coming um before i start
do you want to plug
um before i start do you want to like
plug um tell them where they can find
you i usually do that in the beginning
yeah sure i have a youtube channel
called playing with fire you can just um
you know type in tinder text game which
is playing with fire you'll find me i
have a website called playing fire.com
we have a lot of free tutorials and
guides so you can check all that out
okay cool um how would you describe your
channel
i would describe it as a no [ __ ]
practical
strategy to succeed in online dating and
just dating in general and everything
that's related to that like for example
if you want to do better on tinder you
should probably get in shape so how to
put on muscle um that but the primary
focus is giving like practical no
[ __ ] strategies that guys can like
apply
mm-hmm
um so i know we've talked a lot about a
little bit about the red pill and
occasionally making fun of fresh and fit
um i know when i was on your channel we
talked a little bit about the red pill
um i wanted to know as a dating coach
from your perspective what is the
biggest mistakes that you see men make
in dating
um for both red pill and not red pill
sure i mean there's so many um
first of all like i would say that i
think kevin ray wilder makes this point
is that it shouldn't really be called
the red pill it should be called the
rolo pill because it's really a lot of
it is just based on stuff that role
tomasi says uh because red pill implies
like you know you're scripting for the
truth right which i don't really think
the red book community wants to do
anymore it's more just like confirming
their you know whatever they say so
they're looking for confirmation bias
but going back to the question what
mistakes do you guys make
i think a lot of guys don't really
understand women
and
how women's minds work and how
attraction works in general so a lot for
example some guys the most basic level
would be like thinking that once you hit
all these logical check marks that you
can attract girls like okay so you know
i make 100k a year why doesn't she like
me like i told her
a year or like telling the girl hey i'm
a high value guy okay like that doesn't
do much for a girl like you're just
being told that like i'm a high value
guy should be attracted to me um also
not understanding
why girls do some of the things they do
so for example a girl might give a guy a
[ __ ] test right over text her on a date
right because she wants to see how he's
going to react
you know like a guy's guy's coming off
as like a cool guy but she wants to make
sure he's really that guy he's not going
to like change his tune when giving a
little bit of adversity but guys might
think that oh she's doing that because
she's disrespecting me so they might get
like overly aggressive or they might get
butthurt or something like that and they
lose the date a lot of guys also get
super duper needy when the girl doesn't
reply and they assume it's because the
girl found a better guy or because she's
you know getting slammed by like five
other dudes right now in reality she's
just like sleeping or like you know like
stuck in traffic that's why she didn't
text you back so i really think that
like this can really run the gamut
there's a lot of we can get more into
that but yeah there's so there's so many
mistakes that guys make but they all
stem from just not really understanding
women and how attraction works
well i think what you said is very true
about like checking the boxes like
sometimes i'll see such an entitlement
from guys um like oh i'm fit i i make
this amount of money i do this this and
this like why don't women like be
um and i think that's like one of the
biggest i guess misconceptions i see
because i've seen some broke dudes like
pull very attractive females like left
and right
for sure i used to be broke for a
significant portion of my life um i was
doing pretty good like between the age
of 24 and 28 i had pretty much no money
but i was doing pretty good with women
because i was already in like heavily
into game by then
so um if a guy comes to you and he he
has no idea what he's doing with women
like never had a girlfriend never
like barely can talk to girls how do you
start like how does a guy start when he
wants to learn about women
oh man is he like a virgin in this
situation
um yeah let's let's say he's a virgin
yeah so
the first thing i want to do is i want
to get that client some level of success
under his belt because i think a lot of
times
the virgin guys they've been trying for
a while and they've just been failing so
they're in a very negative headspace
they're like at the point where they're
like debating giving up they're debating
like ah
sex is not for me or whatever like um
so i want to get them some like
level of confidence and success so what
i might do at that point is i might set
up a um it also depends if they're in
like decent looking or they're like
obese or something like that let's
assume the person is decent looking
um i'll just set up a pretty
sex
sex-positive
dating profile for them on tinder right
and make it pretty sexual i would teach
them like very you know sexual texting
that they can do that would basically do
the work for them and then get the girl
straight over their place so that point
all they have to do is like show up and
like not have some kind of seizure and
they will get laid then once they start
having that then i you know
progressively challenge them okay now
let's do without the sex thing so now
the girl comes over but you still have
to like talk to her now let's do a
public date now let's do a little cold
approach right so just progressively up
the ante uh but yeah it sounds a lot
easier than it is because this [ __ ]
takes time because there's a lot of like
[ __ ] up like i've had some virgin
clients where i would just help them
like get to like the girl comes over and
still [ __ ] it up somehow like i'm like
dude she was at your place and she
called uncle and said i can't wait to
suck that [ __ ] and you still manage like
not to get laid um
so yeah so it just depends on how
socially autistic the person is how
awkward they are and what their level of
looks is
what what sort of messages would you
send on tinder to like get a girl over
to your place to the point
i just can't imagine like a super
unattractive like profile
um like getting that many girls to come
over like how do you overcome that yeah
so it would it would not be uh it would
not be a super attractive profile so
this is assuming the guys are good
looking right so i would have not picked
out the best photos i would help them do
that but if the guy is like you know out
of shape or something like that there's
no way to do that like that person would
have to go to the gym and would have to
like you know put on muscle which takes
time he would have to like upgrade his
stop um so yeah if if you are like you
know in bad shape or something like that
then that's not possible it's going to
be much longer road for you
okay so you actually would would you
advise like improving your life first
for some clients before they could even
attract a woman
i would try doing both at the same time
i mean
guys often act like they're so busy like
they have only have like time for one
thing like oh you know yeah some
self-improvement don't have time for
girls like meanwhile they only like work
or anything but yeah i would just i
would recommend doing both
yeah oh it's interesting when i went to
um like john anthony's camp i'm gonna
release a video about it like soon
um but i didn't realize how hard it is
for guys like it is
it's like a lot more difficult than it
is for girls to um
get laid i guess
like
the amount of approaches you have to do
to like get a yes
yeah it definitely is like even if you
get good like i would consider myself
pretty good at like you know talking to
girls and whatnot but like i just like
yesterday yesterday
yeah yesterday we were at south beach um
we were filming some infield yeah like i
remember like go up to a girl right like
my first approach like really hot girl
and like it just like there's all these
like random factors to her at starbucks
and then like as i'm talking to her like
they called her name so at that point
like i can't just like creepily stand
close behind her so i have to kind of
like stop i'm like she's gonna be after
she's done with her order she's gonna
come my way and then like she goes
outside i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm like okay
okay like let me i want to get my
drinker go outside oh she's with a
friend [ __ ] i go up start talking to
them oh the friend starts giving me [ __ ]
uh so it's just like all these obstacles
and my
girl has a boyfriend [ __ ] like oh yeah
you're cool but i'm in a serious
relationship like goddammit um so
there's like definitely
even if you get good there's still like
a high level of you know like approaches
that you have to do and what most i
guess dating coaches won't ever admit is
that most of your interactions will
result in a quote-unquote rejection
what is a good success rate um in terms
of let's just say getting numbers for
like day game
like for for a coach or a good student
in uh in a first world country like
america
is or columbia in america would probably
like
because
it
be
i would say 40 40 to 50 percent of solid
if like every other approach results in
a number that's really solid
um 25 even is still pretty decent that's
actually higher than i was expecting to
be honest because i was in sales um
oh my god hold on
adam could you be quiet i'm not alive
oh my gosh sorry i like share
event with my brother um
sorry um i have a br my brother is like
next door to me my little brother adam
and he's just like yelling for god knows
what reason i thought i heard you say i
shared bed with my brother no no event
like the event goes from my room to
history
um no that's higher than i was expecting
though like i worked in sales and i
think of like a lot of what i see in
like um like dating advice for men like
seems to just be communication and it
was very similar to what i saw in sales
um a lot of times
and so like 40 to 50 would be like a
crazy good rate but you got to keep in
mind most phone numbers
the question was phone numbers most
phone numbers won't result in hookups
right so
for every i would say something like
for every other girl will either not
respond or should be like no response
we'll give you like one word answers so
out of those numbers 50 will actually be
engaging in the conversation and out of
those how many will actually be
maybe another 50
so it comes down to that you get to meet
up with 25 percent of your numbers um so
at the end it comes down to wow
15 10 15 20 success rate
okay and do you feel like uh maybe you
woke up with every girl you meet up with
right so maybe hook up with like 60 so
it just gets like
um and what are good openers that guys
can use when they're going up to a girl
um
you just grab them by the [ __ ] as our
former president used to say no i mean
i'm just [ __ ] alright
i mean i don't really think there's such
thing as a magical opener or anything
like that where you can you know there's
like one line you can use i like to do
situational stuff so i like to just
like for example let's say a girl is
wearing a um
i don't know a notre dame sweatshirt or
something like that i'd be like i'm like
oh that's my favorite team she's like
real epic now i'm just kidding but
i want to meet you real quick like i
would try to do some situational stuff
like if i'm at a grocery store and the
girl is like you know looking at like
something like whatever tacos or
something like that shells i might be
like oh don't get those she'd be like
really i'm like yeah they're the worst
she's like oh [ __ ] really and i'll be
like no i'm just [ __ ] around like i
don't know like i try to like think of
something that's like situational and in
the moment uh if she has a dog i'll
comment on the dog but anything that
kind of isn't too direct and then i
transition into something more direct
well that also puts a lot of like the
pressure off of it because it's not like
you're going up and like giving her a
super big compliment or like asking her
out right away like it almost makes it a
little easier on the guy i would imagine
yeah well i think it also makes it like
because girls even if she finds you
attractive she doesn't want to have to
decide yes or no right away right
right especially if you like
i think that when most girls when they
get approached by a guy
there's like a level of anxiety that
goes up and then it just gets lowered
and lowered
[Music]
you know acts like a normal person so
even if she finds you attractive like
you go up to her she like her little
anxiety's here so you say hey you're
really cute you know can i get your
number she might just say oh no like as
an auto response and then when she goes
over there she's like wait i should have
given him my number he was actually kind
of cute
so i think you can just avoid a lot of
that by just like coming in like a
little bit under the radar
and then building a little comfort
and then kind of transitioning it
towards the you know the date
well that's the one thing i feel like
guys don't understand about girls is we
are so indecisive like we do not know
like
so a lot of times it's just like
building that com comfortability you
know and like making us feel comfortable
enough to give you our number because we
don't know if you're a creep
yeah no i definitely would not recommend
like going for the number like right
away or i don't like to do any
compliments they're like too strong
i would never say like oh my god
or anything like that uh as in terms of
compliments it might be like you know
the center might be oh i really like
that shirt or like oh that's like a cool
color or something like that something
like very nonchalant also i think it's
important when you're giving a
compliment to give a compliment
based on um
something
that's that the girl had to work on like
her style her you know like something
that's not inherent like her her eyes
for example her ass you know most of the
time that's like kind of she was born
with that but girls want to be
compliment on things that they actually
have to work for like this
you know whatever stuff like that
i'm sorry do you hear him
oh i'm gonna kill him later
um
no i agree with that i will exercise my
freedom of speech
when i want it
whenever i want it
adam shut up
could you just be quiet for like an hour
yes please
don't ever move home i swear to god
i wasn't planning on it
okay um
okay so approach you guys smash that uh
super chat so just pearly things can uh
get her own place
okay i want to look at some of the
questions in the chat i feel like
there's a couple for you uh how many um
do you do like one-on-ones with with
clients or is it usually more of a group
setting like i went to
i do i do one-on-ones i um
i have like two types of things i do i
have like a mastermind group so most
people do that and sometimes i do
one-on-ones
i don't do like boot camps or anything
like that
do you think it's over if the guy is
short
depends
a lot of black pill guys will talk about
that if a guy is like
below five five like he's not gonna be
able to get girls do what do you think
about that i mean i think it's
definitely gonna be harder for that guy
for sure but i know guys who are short
who still get girls um is it gonna be
harder yeah but i mean i would i would
think that like
the black pillow community talks a lot
about like oh you know whenever you give
a counter example like well i know this
one guy that's oh that's just anomaly
like that's not the median but i would
make the argument that if you're in that
category you want to be the anomaly you
want to be the exception like why would
you be like oh i guess you
i don't know it's like if let's say you
get like some kind of like bad disease
that 70 of people who get die but 30
live
like
to me i would be like okay what do i
need to do to become part of that 30
percent right yeah
like it's not just
well and like what else are they
supposed to do like you could either
give up or you could try like that's
literally all you can do
i think that the black bill community
makes it seem like
trying and requires you to lose
something so every time you try you lose
something like that if you can scrap
that mindset because you really in
reality you don't lose anything by
trying right besides your time like yeah
doing anything anyway if you're like you
know talking [ __ ] on the internet so
yeah i just think that like i don't see
it as like a you know as a situation
where i have anything to lose by trying
yeah and at worst case you just get
better at communication right like you
can use that wherever you go
yeah i mean there's definitely shorter
guys who get laid but it's definitely
harder for them but no i don't think so
i think you would focus on maximizing
all the things you can like your fitness
like try to get jacked um you know try
to
maximize your social circle your
communication your you know your style
and all that
um how do you tell the difference
between a girl who's resistant and a
girl who's wasting your time
who's resistant though
um
i'm trying to think like what does
resistant mean like she she's just
playing hard to get is that what he's
asking
um the way i'm understanding that
question between a girl who's just like
maybe unsure and a girl who's just using
you for validation
okay um
i would say
i would say investment is a big part of
it so if we're talking about texting at
this point
if she is giving like short one-word
answers and just like maybe like less
than the sentence then generally that
means she's not that interested if she's
investing but maybe she's changing her
mind like one day she's like a little
hot one day she's a little cold and that
would be more of like an unsure type of
situation but she's always just being
low investment that would take that to
me that she's not interested
what do you think of like the nice guy
versus like like the alpha versus beta
narrative like they women don't like the
nice guy they just want the [ __ ] like
what do you think of all of that
i think there's definitely a lot of
truth to it i think like women there's
like this paradox that women find
themselves in because
they like especially a woman who's
trying to settle down she's like okay
well i need a guy who wants to be in a
monogamous relationship who's going to
be committed
but i'm not attracted to that nice guy
i'm attracted to that kind of like
cheeky alpha [ __ ]
that's not the guy that wants to settle
down that's like the paradox right
because and so what girl's trying to do
she's trying to find that like best of
both worlds but that's basically unicorn
because those guys are very rare like
most guys are either going to be in one
category or another so i think that's
like the paradox that every girl who
wants to settle down finds herself in oh
i definitely think there's no amount of
treat to it um you can be
a nice human being without being a nice
guy
um like i would consider myself in that
category like i'm generally nice to
people i wouldn't consider myself a nice
guy by any stretch
but it usually requires either a really
good upbringing or that you did a lot of
work on yourself and i'm like in the
latter category
well i also think it's like the ability
for guys to banter is very attractive
because you're not like putting her on a
pedestal so that's why i kind of liked
your openers where you kind of say oh no
i hate the team or you kind of like give
her [ __ ] a little bit like i think
that's really good because women like we
don't like to be like treated like we're
not human
right yeah i mean i think a lot of guys
they like really put these girls on
pedestals and then
yeah i mean i think that's awkward
dynamic for the girl and also if you put
some on a pedestal like generally people
will try to act the way you perceive
them so for example if i go on a date
with a girl i treat her like as like
angel who's super pure she's probably
not gonna sleep with me on the first
night she's probably gonna play into
that role like if i treat her like you
know like hey listen i know what's up i
know women are sexual like i get it like
blah blah blah
then there's more likelihood that she's
gonna fill that role of like a girl
who's like you know dtf or whatever um
but yeah i definitely it's never a good
idea to put a girl on a pedestal
what is some other advice that you give
to guys
um
like what are your main like i know
that's a broad question i just feel like
what like what are your main tenets in
like your course
yeah that's uh okay let me think of like
the best way to explain that um if we're
talking about like overall game and
self-improvement
i would say
one
avoid being a victim at all costs try to
take responsibility for as much things
as you can
um
i think like a lot of guys like to play
victim a lot like you see this a lot in
the red pill and black book community
like oh i'm you know i have a this you
know that's why girls don't like me oh
you know it's modern feminism blah blah
blah and there's elements of truth to
all that but you still want to try to
i guess not be a victim as much as
possible and try to take control so for
that short guy okay yeah you're short
you know something to do about that but
you can get like you know uh boots they
increase your height by two inches right
you can get jacked you can get you know
you can work on your finances you can
work on your game work on social skills
you can do more approaches than the tall
guy right so you kind of make up for
that by volume so let's say a tall guy
has a 20 success rate a short guy has a
five percent success rate and the show
guy has to approach four times as much
but he does that he'll generally like
bounce out i'm just pulling these
numbers out my ass
uh so generally try to do as much as you
can
given whatever circumstances
are too diversified so i think a lot of
guys are like oh you know i'm on you
know i do day games so you know i don't
need online or whatever uh try to
diversify as much as possible or like
i'm on tinder i don't need to like meet
girls in real life try to be on tinder
bumble hinge day game night game um you
know meet girls through your friends
whatever like whenever you have
opportunities you want to just be as
diverse as possible
um i would say three
stop being sold so easily a lot of guys
get sold on girls like super fast
without knowing anything about them try
to like
be more like the skeptical buyer you're
like you're like weary a little bit
right like you're not you're not giving
the girl your complete stamp of approval
right away you're like kind of like
you're kind of seeing what she's all
about uh four try to make things as easy
as possible for yourselves in terms of
logistics a lot of guys will like set up
these like dates where like they're
meeting them like the girl like an hour
away from their place and all that [ __ ]
they don't have a car like that's gonna
be really hard to close so just try to
be like as strategic as possible like
if a girl wants to be in public that's
fine but i meet her at a bar that's near
my place it's like walking distance so
it's very easy for me to bring her back
i mean those were the big ones off top
of my head
do you uh
do you um
do you suggest that guys like do like
what's the most effective do you think
night game day game or dating apps
i think dating apps are the most
efficient but
um you can probably meet a high caliber
of girls in real life
there's pros and cons to both or if you
have a good profile probably the most
efficient
but yeah there's definitely advantages
to meeting girls in real life
like dave universe night game i think
probably night game is better and more
effective uh simply because you have
more girls in like a closer area
and uh also because generally speaking
more of the girls you're gonna be more
of the single girls gonna be going out
at night versus during the daytime
they're gonna have a lot of girls have
boyfriends and whatnot
um
where do you recommend that guys meet
like quality girls because you always
see like people in the red pill like
complain about not being able to meet
quality girls
um where do you think that's
like what do you think's the best way to
overcome that like guys that don't
really want like a party girl
yeah well i think a big part of it is
where you live so if you're living in
like um like a city like miami los
angeles
if you move to like the midwest or you
know the south or whatever like you know
second-tier cities
um you're going to have a way higher
likelihood of meeting a quality girl so
certain cities attract certain kinds of
people there's still good people in like
all those cities
these are two places where i personally
live
but you know they're fewer and far in
between
um another thing is like where you're
actually going so like the the you know
like that nice
sweet girl she's not going to be going
to a club most of the time at least not
like
so where you have to think like where
did she go well maybe she does crossfit
right you want athletic girl so maybe
you would like meet her at the gym or
you join like a class or something like
that or yoga or something like that um
you know maybe she is you know walks her
dog or takes him to the dog parks and
maybe you'll go there we kind of have to
like reverse engineer it um but i think
a lot of guys are looking for like the
quality girls or clubs and [ __ ] and
they're not funny
like why is that
well that's like unfresh and fit that's
what i asked them when i was on their
show i was like do you guys think you're
maybe in a bubble like in miami like i
do
because i was involved in like college
sports like that's how i met all my
friends with sports like that was
literally all i did up until
i was 21.
so
i i'm like where are you guys meeting
these females like all my friends had
like stuff to do
well like we did not have time for this
like being flown out to different cities
every weekend or whatever this like
craziness is
it's it's such a funny paradox that
fresh finds themselves in because they
want it it's so ironic because they they
like they want them like the kind of the
traditional conservative girl that's who
they idolize that kind of like the you
know that good girl right
but uh because of their you know brand
that girl will never go on their podcast
so the kind of girls they're getting on
their podcast with the exception of you
know pearl obviously the kind of girl
they're getting on their podcast
generally speaking is um
the girl who wants the tag right at this
point that's most of the girls the girls
who want cloud generally speaking unless
that girl is a youtuber or a content
creator she's gonna be like some
instagram you know girl who doesn't
really have a job uh the podcasts are
like like you know late at night so
again on a weekday like those chicks
like the normal chicks who are like you
know doctors nurses you know like
professional girls they're not going to
be able to go on that podcast so that's
the paradox they find themselves in
and we're just very
well because who's gonna be free
midnight to four in the morning on
weekdays
that is a real job like i'm a youtuber
so i could go but who wouldn't a real
job is gonna be able to go
and like what chick who's like who's
like a career woman is gonna at that
point go on the podcast
you know like given the fact that like
you know like especially like all the
kick-outs and [ __ ] like what girl would
really want to do that at that point
right there's gotta be some kind of
incentive and again if you're like you
know hungry for cloud then the incentive
is there but if you don't care about
cloud then what's the point
well and it's so interesting because
like when i was on their show i asked
like what percent of women do you think
are quality right so i think that's why
the red pill gets so mad is because the
red pill just makes it seem like it's
all women right
and i asked them i'm like what percent
they told me five percent i'm like you
think only five percent of women are
quality
like do you think maybe it's the women
that you pick
all the girls that they meet on their
podcast yeah i believe that but that's
not five percent in miami it's probably
closer to like 30 but like overall it's
probably like 50 or something like that
yeah
yeah i mean there's definitely like cool
girls in miami for sure like i met a
bunch of them but there's more cool
girls on average in like you know places
i've traveled to
so yeah but yeah like in terms of you
know like if you're
yeah it's like a funny paradox they find
themselves in
yeah no i was just like [ __ ] because
it's interesting because other content
creators have asked the same question
and they'll they'll say
i feel like if the guys actually
interact with quality women it's closer
to like 30 to 50 percent is what they'll
say which i would agree with
like i i wouldn't disagree that there's
definitely ratchet chicks out there like
it definitely exists
but
i think like 30 is a pretty solid number
yeah no i would i would co-sign that
it's definitely not five percent though
like that would have had
19 out of 20 girls out of my math is off
19 out of 20 girls that i meet suck
which i really don't think is the case
like i think it's closer to like half
and half there's definitely some tricks
that suck but it's not like 19 and a
half 20. like that it's not even nine
out of 10.
so if a guy is uh looking for a
long-term partner do you have do you do
that like relationship coaching or you
just like strictly
um like be the beginning you know no i
haven't done that yeah um
yeah no i i have done that um
oh was that the question or do you want
me
no the question is um what qualities do
you tell men to look for in women that
they date
yeah um
well i think the there's qualities that
i'll look for which might be different
than the qual there's some qualities
that every guy should look for when
there's some qualities they're specific
to me
um
so let's start off with i guess what i
look for in a girl for long term um i
look for intelligence like i just can't
really be with a girl long term who i
think is dumb um but maybe if you're
like pretty dumb guy then that's not a
big deal for you um i don't know maybe
that was not like a requirement so
intelligence loyalty i think that one is
goes without saying uh honesty so if i
ever catch the girl in the y that's like
that's like the beginning of the end
um
i like i'm not talking about like little
white lies like hey babe i'll be there
nine o'clock and she comes at like 9 30
or something like that i'm talking about
like substantialize
um
any kind of um
a girl who i feel like
some girls have this habit of like bun
pushing where they're constantly trying
to like
test their guys
and
any kind of in the initial stages i'll
allow some of that but if we're together
and you i see that you're doing that
then that's like that's not never going
to work um
any kind of um
self-sabotage
at least in terms of like relationships
like some chicks really do sell sabotage
when things are going well for them so
if i find that then that's probably not
going to work out
um
what do you mean by self-sabotage
yes like some tricks when things start
going well for them they just find a way
to like [ __ ] it up
um they will like literally sabotage
their relationship
like how just by like hooking up with a
different guy or starting a fight or
yeah
either one of those things exactly like
and she doesn't even she didn't really
want to hook up with that guy she didn't
even really still want to start that
fight she just has like some internal
trauma that has been fixed since her
childhood
and her self-image doesn't like her
internal i guess whatever equilibrium
doesn't allow her to be happy for an
extended period of time so that girl at
that point either needs to go to therapy
or like you know whatever do some kind
of work on yourself uh but i'm not going
to be like that therapist for her
you know like at least not if it's like
a girlfriend
i'm trying to think she has to have a
good sense of humor like i really don't
like all this politically correct
nonsense
um
so she has a good sense of humor just to
get my sense of humor
um
she has to i want a girl who like
is passionate like
i don't know how to explain it like a
girl who can get behind what i do so for
girls like for any reason like ashamed
of like you know my career or whatever
then that'll never work and that almost
never happens but like most girls think
it's cool but i want the girl to be like
really on board with like what i do
um
i would say those are like the big ones
off my head i'm sure there's more
like i
mean this i think i want a girl who's
like sweet that's why i tend to need a
lot of nurses
[Music]
are there any red flags that you tell
guys to look out for in women yeah so
many i mean i guess like the opposite of
a lot of stuff i said like um
if she is
playing games or causing drama for no
reason then that's a big red flag uh if
she is lying or being manipulative in
any way that's a big red flag
um
[Music]
if she is trying to like
put you up against other guys or she's
trying to like i guess it falls into
manipulation like she's like oh but like
this guy did this for me like what are
you gonna do like anything like that
that'd be like an instant deal breaker
um that's so awkward have the girl said
that to you before
um
the initial dating stages like when i
like first go on a date yeah i don't
have like some girls have a red flag oh
if she shows up her ass on instagram
that's a red flag i don't believe in any
of that
it's not a big deal uh i mean if we're
like in an exclusive relationship and
she's constantly showing off her ass
that's a different story but like you
know like some guys say oh a girl has an
instagram that's a red flag i think
that's all nonsense
oh yeah or delete your social media if
you get into a relationship
that's so dumb i would never ask my girl
to delete her social media
i
i understand a little bit like the
attention seeking like you don't even if
you're posting like a picture of your
butt in a relationship it's like what is
the point of that
you know
it's like it's like
validation and like attention seeking
you don't think so
it is but it'll be so
hypocritical of me to call her out for
that when i do the same thing with like
i put out youtube videos and i'm guilt
any youtuber is guilty of like seeking
some level of validation because when we
put out a video we're looking at the
youtube analytics and
a little bit of a high and low based on
our videos any [ __ ] youtuber has some
level of that so i'm not gonna like
criticize her for literally something i
do just in a different way uh it just
it's the levels of it
everyone likes validation and a little
value speaking
i don't see as problematic massive
validation seeking yeah it's a different
story
well i think there's a difference
between like i don't know like a youtube
video
versus like i would put a gym mirror
selfie like a ab selfie for guys it's
the same thing as like a butt picture
for girls
like to me like that's the equivalent i
literally like put one of those up like
three days ago
uh my goal wasn't validation though my
goal was possibly partially validation
well my goal was just to like set up a
third strap for some tricks i'm talking
to you off instagram
which is a side note it works if you're
in good shape
but
yeah there's just different levels of it
like i think you know like let's take
the girl who i'm with now uh she has her
instagram set on private so it's not
like she even talks to like people off
instagram but she does occasionally like
if she's like traveling to mexico she
does like you know take a picture of
herself in a bikini and like you know
she kind of angles it so you can see her
ass like she does i know she does that
but that doesn't bother me like oh in
any way
she wasn't engaging those guys and
that's a different story
do you ever coach guys to like try to
get an ex back or anything like try to
like win someone back have you ever done
that yes
because guys have insisted on it i
always try to talk them out of having me
coach them on that because i always
think it's a bad idea and almost never
works um but some of them insist like
alex i know you said there's one percent
chance i'll pay you please please please
please and i'll be like okay fine uh but
i always try to talk them out of it and
it almost never works
i was gonna ask if it what do you tell
them
to get nice back really depends on the
situation and like how much they [ __ ]
it up and where it's at and it just
would really be situational
i'm just curious if you and i would say
the same thing
so that's why i wanted to know oh crap
yeah i just i think it really depends on
the situation i mean generally speaking
there's a reason the girl is an ex
for whatever reason i also think that
there's
three components to a relationship
there's you there's her and then there's
the relationship which is almost a
separate entity and so
let's say let's say okay let's say
whatever like you and i have a
relationship right and when we're
younger and it goes bad for whatever
reason like i cheat you cheat or
whatever and then we both get single we
both go to therapy we both get a lot
better we're both a lot self-aware and
we get back together
but it's still not starting with a blank
slate because there's all that baggage
and history in the past so that the
relationship aspect never goes away so
even if you have improved as a guy or
she's changed as a girl there's still
that relationship and there's still
going to be some level of resentment
which you just really can't get past so
that's why i'm a much bigger believer in
like starting off on a fresh slate with
a new girl
rather than obsessing over an ex that
probably isn't even nearly as great as
you made her out to be in your mind
yeah well and
we we hold grudges females like we do
not let stuff go
well you think so i feel like girls are
so much worse with grudges
probably but i think some guys hold
grudges forever too
really
i don't know
see because if i was gonna tell a guy to
like try to get like back a girl i would
tell him to like
don't like talk to her at all like don't
give her any validation
because i feel like
like if you chase her like she's not
gonna like want you back you know what i
mean
very true but that's only gonna work if
she is still somewhat interested and
she's hitting him up if she has if she's
at the point where she's moved on she's
not actually hitting him up
just ignoring her it's not going to do
anything right well but then you went
either way because then you like lose
someone that like didn't even want you
right i mean
but then the guy's still like like [ __ ]
how do i get her back like
yeah
i mean i think a lot of those situations
are like inherently [ __ ] to begin with
but yeah when you have a situation where
the girl she's your ex but she's still
actively like stalking her instagram
she's still you know pinging you and
texting you back from time to time
there's still that level of interest and
investment that's going to be like 100
times easier than a chick who's just
like okay well i'm doing my own thing
now
um do you teach guys to like have a
rotation or do you just um teach them to
like get in relationships like what type
of guys typically come to you
most of the guys that come to me want
rotations but it really just depends on
i don't believe there's a right or wrong
i just think it depends on what that
person wants um
most guys do want rotation so i help
them like get that but some guys want
relationships and i like try to help
them get that too um i don't believe
that there's like i think there's
there's a lot of like judgment with
dating like oh you know you want to be
you know with a rotation you're like
just a [ __ ] boy or something like that i
don't believe in any of that i don't
i'll assign like moral judgment to
whatever
dating goals someone has no matter how
like i'm starting i have
50 year old clients who want to bang
like 18 year old chicks right like
i don't like assign moral judgments to
that like even though i probably
wouldn't do that if i was a 50 year old
maybe i would i don't know
well that's what like people think it's
odd uh with my demeanor that like i go
like i went to like a pickup conference
right like people think that's odd but
like i don't understand like why do i
care if i'm not the one banging them you
know what i mean if they're both
consensual like what what does it matter
to me you know
yeah what was what was like some of the
criticism that you were getting on my
feedback for that
um it sounds really criticism people are
just like surprised like i would be the
last person they would expect to go
just because like i'm kind of like more
like traditional in terms of like my
upbringing and like i would be the last
person to like want to be in a rotation
you know what i mean just like stuff
like that
um and some girl
i'm sorry and some girls just get kind
of mad with pick up like they do not but
i don't understand what's so bad about
it it's mostly just like communication
to be honest
yeah i think i think well i think that
the reason that some people might be
surprised that you go to a pickup
conference simply has to do with the
fact that you're a girl so it's like why
is a girl showing interest in something
that
isn't like
i don't know how to it would be like
i don't know why why would a guy who's
like a paraplegic be so interested in
bodybuilding or something like that you
know i mean
so not applicable to that person or i
don't know something like someone who's
blind like be so interested in art or
something like that
um
so it's just interesting that you have
developed this like kind of like
fascination
with something that's predominantly you
know male dominated well it's kind of
interesting to see like what would work
on me like when guys talk about it i'm
like i wonder if that would work so one
thing that i heard um
that i felt like was really true when
it's like establishing touch with a girl
pretty early on to show her that you're
comfortable in your body
because how is she supposed to be
comfortable with you if you like
yeah if you're not comfortable with
yourself and i felt like that was really
true
um do you agree with that or no 100
um
yeah because
it's just like small stuff like that but
you can even say that if i i was in
a business relationship right like
people tend to like people that like
touch them but not like weird you know
like i don't know if i feel like
everyone's like a conference meeting
with like some dude and we're debating
talk working together he's like touching
me a lot that's gonna make me like now i
want to work with him like dude like i
don't know about this he's trying to pay
me or something
maybe maybe it says but i feel like like
when you touch people on like their
elbow or like their shoulder just like
let in like a weird way i don't know
there's like a normal way to do it
if you're a girl and you're touching a
guy i think most guys would be behind
that but like i think most dudes like
stray dudes don't want like other dudes
touching them like too much
like that would just be like that kind
of weirded me out if a guy's like
touching my elbow and [ __ ] like he's
like massaging my shoulder yeah so we're
gonna sign the contract
i didn't think about that i think i
think i'm in a different position just
because i'm a girl
yeah i think it is different as a girl
what is like some of the like worst
like dating advice that you heard that
you were like this would never in a
million years work on me
oh gosh uh
the worst one i think i told you on your
podcast but just the
um if you don't sleep with me i'm gonna
call another girl
oh yeah i feel like okay you could do
that then especially on like
because my thing is i know people it's
like the third date is when people like
expect the other to sleep with them but
i feel like i barely know someone on the
third date so if someone said that to me
in a third day i'd be like i literally
don't know you because i think of like a
dating app you know
i think he was talking about doing that
on the first date i don't think there
would even be a second date oh gosh
that's how i understood it i could be
wrong but i understood as like you don't
give her like a girl who doesn't [ __ ]
you in the first game like you don't
give her a second chance
um
i actually there's one at the pickup
conference there's one line that i
thought was really bad and i'm trying to
remember what it was
um oh when they say can i kiss you
um what do you think about that because
i did not like that i felt like that was
kind of weird yeah i never asked for
permission to like kiss or like escalate
um because i think that
yeah i i think most girls get turned off
by that like when you're asking for
permission
so yeah i just go for the kiss
what are um as a dating coach what are
the best fruits first dates that you
would recommend guys take a girl on
i always recommend the guys keep it
super simple guys often love to over
complicate it like i'm gonna take her on
a magical pony ride and then we're gonna
like i don't know they try to woo her
with a date
my the best first date you can do is
either drinks at your place or drinks at
a bar nearby that's it suppose that
what is the best way to increase the
response rate on dating apps
get a better profile so if you have a
really attractive profile not only we
get more matches but the matches you do
get will be more responsive and we've
like tested that um because a lot of
times like
like girls will naturally the guy who's
maybe average but then she's like yeah i
don't really want to talk to him or she
just matched him because maybe she felt
it at the moment because she laughed at
his bio but she's like yeah i can't see
myself going out with him so getting
better photos will definitely increase
the response rate um
being leaving not
saying things like like
making sending texts are easy for her to
respond to so
if you send me a text like hey how's
your day going i say oh it's pretty good
that's hard for you to respond to and
you're gonna have to be way less likely
to respond but if i say oh it's pretty
good took my dog uh to the park uh he
had a fun little day playing with all
the other rugrats how about you there's
a lot you can respond to you could talk
about dogs you can talk about you know
how your day was so just sending texts
are easy the person doesn't have to
think about how to respond to
no that's really true there's nothing
worse than a guy that doesn't know how
to text and you feel like you're
carrying the whole conversation
yeah like hey what's up
how are you
because especially as a female like we
have so many you know we have so many
options just in general so it's like if
one guy's not like doesn't know how to
text it's like why would i take the
energy to figure out how to like make a
connection with him you know
right yeah it's a super competitive
marketplace for guys so you have to like
use every edge the good news is that
most guys really suck at game and
texting so
you're like it's pretty easy to be like
a top 10 in terms of like your text game
what do you think the best way
um
that guys can looks match them i think
they call it look snatch in the um
manosphere yeah how would you recommend
guys do that
uh one go to high-end barbershop and
have them um like do your your car like
so you can see like kind of those are
like you know it's like all nice and
lined up i got a skin fade everything's
like even on my facial hair so i kind of
you know pretty even like my beard is
nice so i go once a week which is a
little excessive but that's honestly
because i'm a youtuber so like part of
my you know revenue is just like looking
sharp
i wasn't a youtuber probably once every
two weeks uh but yeah just having you
know like everything like lined up at a
good barber shop
don't be cheap uh the second thing is
just getting clothes that fit you well
so a lot of dudes walk around with
shirts that are just too loose um you
want shirts that just like sit nicely on
your butt this is not actually the best
example it sure it's a little loose but
um generally like i wouldn't wear this
on a date for example but yeah you want
clothes that's so well on your body um
another one is just going to the gym and
putting on muscle like i think every guy
can benefit from putting on 20 30 pounds
of muscle as most guys um muscle will
make your clothes fit better you look
more masculine you look more dominant
also i think that's a that's a big one
um
i think those are like the big ones you
know that you have control over um i'm
not like a big fan of like getting
surgeries or stuff like that unless
you're like super deformed
i think a good haircut goes a long way
for sure okay someone in the chat said
and if anyone has questions in the chat
feel free to put them um i disagree with
wasting a lot of time to build rapport
isn't it true that the longer you talk
without proposing dating and exchanging
info it shows timidness and creeps her
out
no i definitely don't think it cree you
can creep a girl out by not proposing a
date like this guy's so creepy he didn't
ask me on a date like
like if you think about logically it
doesn't really make sense but in terms
of the timidness
yes if but everything is like
within reason so if you're talking to
her for weeks and you haven't proposed a
date then that does show that you're
timid and she is going to get bored but
you don't want to go to the other
extreme and like suggest the date within
the first few texts because then she's
just doesn't have enough information to
decide on whether she likes you or not
so there's like a happy balance there
what i like to do is i like to get some
investment from the girl i get the
conversation started get her really
talking and then i propose the date so
i don't think you should waste a lot of
time but you shouldn't waste a little
bit of time to
get her to invest and get the columns
started
so how how much time would you recommend
like
talk to her for a day and then propose a
date two days it really has nothing to
do with like whether it's days it's more
has to do with like it's because it
depends is she replying every five
minutes or she's replying twice a day
but it just more has to do with the
level of investment that she's shown the
conversation like the whether it's been
a few hours or a few days doesn't really
matter as much as how much you know text
there are how many screenshots of
conversation there is so i would
probably measure in terms of screenshots
worth of combo rather than time uh in
terms of screenshots worth of convo i
would say at least two screenshots worth
of conversation ideally like three or
four probably
oh that's not that much that's not like
crazy at all no no nothing yeah i don't
yeah it's fairly still fairly fast well
i just don't think you should like go
for the date right away like
right off within the first x
um i have never heard of modern life
dating but
free is asking if you'd be willing to
date or i'm not oh my gosh debate
definitely not willing to date him
i don't know like i'm really not a fan
of that guy
because he's like just i think a massive
disgrace to the game
and there's very few people who i would
say that about also because i have a
one of my clients used to work with him
and
mld just like severely abused this guy
to the point where my client was like
suicidal basically
um also there's like a lot of other
shady [ __ ] like this this guy that i was
coaching he was on like a heavy amount
of um klonopin which is benzodiazepine
with those drugs that you can't just
like stop taking them and he was like
just stop taking your medication like
which would have killed him right so
like
that kind of stuff like really rubs me
the wrong way was like as a dating coach
you really shouldn't be giving people
medical advice
um
i'd probably still despite all that
probably still would but i don't know
it's not like something i'm excited
about i'd be more excited to debate like
rolo or like myron or something like
that because at least i consider them
like
my intellectual equals or something like
that like
like they're like at least like i
respect them as like human beings
somewhat you know like versus mld i just
don't really like even respect them as a
good person so
how do
how do guys tell the difference between
like legit dating coaches and like
because it's so easy to just like hire a
couple hookers and say that you get hot
girls like that is so easy to do how can
guys even tell the difference between
someone that's legit and someone that's
not
yeah it's a good question because like
when you get to like the point like you
know there's a saying game recognizes
games so for me it's really easy to
recognize whether someone has game i
don't need to even talk to them i just
watch like five minutes of the content i
can tell uh it's super easy for me but
for the average person i know that's
like not the case
i would say one look for like receipts
so like for example with me if you go on
my website there is
i want to say probably 50
layer reports with screenshots from
start to finish so every
you know screenshot from the opener to
per se yeah i had a lot of fun with you
right like so you can kind of see that i
bought videos
uh also with like the same thing so kind
of look for receipts if it's like a cold
approach dating coach and you want to
look for infield
i would say that's a big one um
yeah i would say receipts on two whether
the stuff they say actually makes sense
like some of the stuff that people say
just makes no logical sense at all so if
something someone says really doesn't
make sense then probably it's
um are there any content creators that
you want to say that give bad advice to
avoid and content creators that you
would recommend outside of yourself
there's so many that give bad advice
it'd be like faster for me to say which
ones don't okay i'll
i'll do i'll do the i'll go through the
big ones mld obviously gives pretty bad
advice um
what's his name richard cooper pretty
bad advice real tomasi somewhat bad
advice some things he says is okay
something's pretty bad um freshman fit
50 50 with them um
let's see who else um there's also a lot
of guys like rsd generally largely bad
advice
um ams seventy percent good advice
thirty percent bad
uh
i'm trying to thank who else or like
some of the big ones just like naming
content creators and i'll tell you if i
think they're literate or not
you named a lot of them um richard
cooper gives bad advice i actually had
him on my channel but i didn't watch
i didn't watch a lot of his pickup stuff
to be honest
um before he came on so i
i didn't actually
like what does he give that's about
advice
he's like
well one thing he constantly talks about
like how not to like you know avoid
single monster with single moms but like
you look at his track credit he like
pretty much only gains like single moms
so like as like he's like whenever i see
hypocrisy when someone does the opposite
of what they do without them it'd be
like if you found out like i'm kind of
known for like you know being the uh
whatever text guy or tinder or whatever
or you found out working on dating apps
you'd be like what the [ __ ] do you like
no i've actually never downloaded tinder
i'm uh just i just fury guy um
yeah um also he's like really big on a
lot of like the hardcore red pill
concepts about how like
what's it called you know oh hypergamy
all women will want to trade up blah
blah blah
which there's a small amount of truth
tube i think it's largely overblown
um so yeah a lot of stuff like that
plus he like
just like weird things that like kind of
rubbed me the wrong way like the fact
that he charges sixteen hundred dollars
an hour like
1600
yeah that's like so [ __ ] excessive
like it's more than
that's more than kevin samuels charges
and i actually think kevin samuels like
can charge that
because he charges
though and he's like pretty well known
well and you can just i don't know you
can just tell there's a level of like
credibility with him
like i can just tell he knows what he's
talking about at least when it comes to
like image and like he has stats to back
everything that he says up pretty much
although i feel like with kevin samuels
like what is he gonna tell you that
you can't figure out for free from
watching his content like he's just
gonna be like like if you're a girl he's
gonna be like you need better your more
realistic expectations blah blah blah if
you're guys gonna be like try to level
up but like what is he really gonna tell
you like you can't really figure out
that's not just
cast any kind of [ __ ]
i like him as a competitor but he's more
like general type of advice versus like
really specific like really strategies
for improvement
i think he is um
a little bit more of like he does style
so he's like an image consultant so he
he like you could go to him for your
social media to like consult about like
your social media your style or um
you're maybe i forget what the third one
here's like three pillars that he talks
about a lot of people don't know that
though because he's just like roasting
women on his
you probably channel into this more than
i have i watch some of it i find him
pretty entertaining
like he's definitely like
uh what do you think of troy francis and
tusk
troy francis i really don't know enough
about him to make a educated judgment i
do know he associates with some shady
people but that doesn't necessarily mean
you know he's shady so i i just haven't
watched enough of him to like make an
educated judgment uh tusk i think he's
assuming jane's tusk um i found him on
my podcast she's like a nice guy um he
didn't really say anything during our
podcast that made me think like oh this
guy's you know full of [ __ ] um so i
think he has at least a decent
understanding of game so i there's
nothing about him like gives a red flag
or anything like that and he seems like
a decent person but i don't know him
super well either
okay well i think that's all my
questions that i have for you
oh but i don't see anything new in the
chat is there anything you wanted to add
as like advice for guys just to close
off the show
yeah i actually want to ask you so what
was the i was watching a video
about um
how freshman fig got like super
pissed off that you bought like your
boyfriend
i didn't really yell at you
i must yeah no it was like um
he cuz one year was supposed to come on
the show like initially right but then
like they're going through all that
controversy and one year's just
management just like said no you can't
go on
um so i never like i just told him that
like he couldn't go on the show anymore
but i was like do you still want me to
go on because you know and so he told me
when to come
but i didn't like
tell him
that like one year was still coming with
me but we're in the lobby right and so
like they could have just told him to
leave bad
but they like let him in the apartment
and then after my boyfriend left and i
was like leaving like yelled at me
and i'm like what because he was just
like don't ever like do that again um
i can't remember it was kind of a while
ago now so i'm trying to remember what
he said but he definitely was like
yelling at me after the show
like i just can't imagine yelling at any
of my guests especially like once or
like other con
like so it's also so funny because they
constantly say like oh if you have a
boyfriend bring them bring them bring
them no they do they don't even tell you
you have to tell them like they only
said that at the time
bring your boyfriends bring your
boyfriends and like also the fact that
your boyfriend is like you know super
big content creator so like i don't know
i think just like my thought processes
like now i have a podcast like if you
bought your boyfriend and you didn't
tell me i probably wouldn't even bring
it up and i was just trying to network
with him because like if he's like so
big on tick tock and [ __ ] like
and if i was like super annoyed by it it
would probably just be like hey you know
in the future like just let me know when
you're bringing something i just can't
imagine yelling at a guest for like
something like that
because like something's so minor like
it's like you keep your shoes on why the
[ __ ] did you take keep your shoes yeah
well and it was just like if they
because the way it works is it's like an
apartment building so we have to wait in
the lobby before we can even come up so
they had to let him in
like if he just um said before like we
went up there that oh your boyfriend
can't come in like we don't
allow that or whatever you didn't tell
us he was coming but like when you
didn't even want to be there like
he was he just came like to be nice but
he like didn't even want to stay and he
did it he only stayed for like a half
hour so he just like
kind of left like went there just to
like support me he wouldn't have cared
if they told him to leave i don't even
see why it matters if you tell him or i
mean i guess it's like a respect thing
but like it's he's still like what is
like you have a waiting like what's the
big deal if there's like someone hanging
out there like i just unless he's like
causing trouble which i'm you know he's
not like
why does it matter if he's like just
sitting there like chilling on his phone
like it just to me it's like so
irrelevant
like so turn around
because i don't know i mean like you're
not like a super big youtuber but you
are a youtuber to like just like burn a
bridge with like another youtuber or
something like so minor
like it would be like you know how like
i came on a little bit late if you're
like [ __ ] you alex like we're done like
we're not collaborating with a minute
late it's just like such a random thing
to like
i don't know burn a bridge about
yeah and
and it's just weird to me that they
waited until he left like why did she
say anything when he was there like just
i don't know it just rubbed me the wrong
way and then people were like
oh you're so two-faced
i'm like guys i said i was gonna make a
video about my experience like i told
them that like before i don't know why
you would yell at me when i said on the
first time i went on that i'm going to
do a video about like my experience i'm
fresh and fit like i i don't know why
you would be surprised that i then made
a video about my experience on fresh and
fit
and then they they like commented on my
video and then like deleted it and i
still have the notification from it
they're just calling me a cloud chaser
that's that's the only defense they want
anyone ever criticizes them like the
police officer could pull them over like
sir you were going 30 miles or speed
you're just a cloud chaser dude i don't
even know
like
that's literally the only defense they
ever have is you're a cloud chaser well
and i was like why do you what
and i'm like why do you make the cut
like if you're gonna comment like stand
on it like don't delay i have the screen
because i screenshotted the notification
you know what i mean and i'm like why
would you
comment it
and then delete it like stand on that
[ __ ] you know
that cloud chaser is like literally the
lamest defense ever
like they will get criticized and i
think some of the criticism they deserve
some of their they don't deserve but
like when there's like criticism they
just only the only response they ever
have is that person is a cloud chaser
no and behind this is more popular than
them less popular like it could be like
[ __ ] like i don't know like you know
like 50 cent or something was like way
more popular than them oh he's just a
clown chaser that [ __ ] 57
well even when like the whole admin
preach thing was going on i was there
like behind the scenes when they were
like talking
and you know it was a while ago so i
can't remember like exactly what they
said but the energy was very much like
they just hate us because they aren't us
like they just want to be us like none
of this like i'm like
you insulted the man's wife like i don't
know
i didn't say that because i was just
like it's not my bit beef you know what
i mean but i'm just sitting there like
let me say oh the haters are gonna hate
i'm like i think you just
you just crossed the line when you
insulted the guy's wife actually
but there's like such a high level of
dissonance that's going on there like
yeah like the crap also like whenever i
make any kind of criticism of like any
red pill youtuber you know like i'd
never go after people personally so i
would never like you know go after like
for example the whole uh myron being in
the uh
uh whenever working for the department
of homeland security i've known about
that for over a year like i know mine he
told me that if i wanted to dock him i
could have done that at any point right
i never did the thought never even
entered my mind because that's personal
to me that's off limits right like
that's his personal life and then
there's the content right and i'm not
like now to go after people personally
like that's not what i do um
but like whenever i so all my criticism
will just be like strictly about the
arguments and sometimes like i like to
like crack jokes and i'll take a little
like you know like jokes that people
shots but it's kind of in good humor you
know what i mean like i'm not yeah
docs you'll grow after you personal uh
personally about things like that and
every time i make a video their fan
voice all they do is just say you're
cloud chaser okay but what about each
one of my five arguments that i made
doesn't matter because you're a cloud
chaser and then like sometimes they even
make that argument like they'll be like
you're you're cloud chasing rollo
like we're almost like the same
popularity level like
like it's like why like at what point
can you criticize someone like so like a
smaller channel is never allowed to
criticize anyone who's bigger than them
because then just makes them a cloud
chaser it just looks like that argument
to me is like so [ __ ]
well and that's the reason the whole
beef started was they got so defensive
about someone criticizing them like i'm
sorry you're not people in general like
i'm not a perfect person i'm sure at
some point someone's gonna criticize me
and i'm sure at some point it's gonna be
valid that's like
what you take when you go on the
internet you know
but you don't even have the humility to
like like even the original video album
preach made it was what was it about it
was oh it's about hookers
and they took that so personally about
them saying that like it's not bad to
get hookers if you're like super high
value or rich and you value your time
like that's not that's not a personal
attack so i don't know why they got so
defensive god damn it we want our
hookers
we're like oh i don't think they get as
many girls as they say like
like if i was a dude and i got like
girls left and right i would not care if
someone said i did it like what do you
care if you know you get girls
they handle that in literally the worst
like if there was ever like a class
being taught in college like and one of
the case studies was how not to handle a
scandal like they did pretty much
everything they could have done wrong
like it's almost like a satire like i
was waiting for the part like guys we're
just [ __ ] with you like we just want
to like you know show you how bad we can
handle this because really made every
possible mistake uh getting super
defensive making it about clout and like
like popularity which was never about at
all uh like yelling into the microphone
we are better than you how is that going
to make your like the audience like you
like like oh okay he yelled into the
microphone he's better than me so that
makes sense and then like yeah it was
just they just handled that so poorly
well it's funny because
it's like god i was gonna say the only
thing they did somewhat right is they
when they have that like big live stream
where they just kind of went through the
screenshots
that's what they should have done
initially and yeah and like mine was
actually i don't know if it was an act
or he was being serious but he was
actually like pretty humble during that
live stream but like everything else was
just like such a level of like
attitude and ego that like i just think
turns so many people off
well and i called it when i was on your
show
do you remember i was talking on your
show like there's no way they get girls
like that like there's no way oh yeah
and then all this stuff comes out that
like they're telling girls to sleep with
them to come on the show
like how
how which i did not do i'd like to like
put that out there i was not asked to do
that
um
but like if you get girls you know what
i mean like if you had
like you would never tell someone to
sleep with you to come to your apartment
and do content
because you know you're a pickup artist
like you know how to get girls
like why would you need to do that
i mean like the level of hypocrisy is
just like insane yeah like uh guys you
should never leave with your wallet but
it's okay to leave with your cloud like
it is
well and then you saw his like sugar
baby profile what did it say it like
literally says
only this percent of the population
makes as much money as me only this
percent of the population has abs i'm
like
that would turn me off so quickly if i
saw that profile
yeah what mario was trying to do which
is something he does quite often he's
trying to logic his way to attraction so
he's trying to give the girl multiple
reasons why she should be attracted it'd
be like i go on again i'm like okay so
here are four reasons why you should go
home with me tonight reason number one i
have
reason number two i'm actually good in
bed if you check my references look what
this girl said yeah i love sucking your
dick because you were so good at like
you can't do that you can't give girls
logical reasons to like find you
attractive i think that's like a lesson
that i don't admire maybe has recently
learned but
maybe he hasn't like even wrote a lesson
that you can't logic your way into like
attraction well they definitely have
changed their tune like after like
they're saying we never said we were
alpha
and that's like they're saying we're
just nerdy guys and this is how
yeah
and like this is just stuff we've
learned about girls along the way
um and i was like i don't know you guys
sounded a little different a couple
months ago
well i i thought i sort of thought that
they changed the tune actually until i
saw your video about like your
experience like i felt like they were
like okay you know we're gonna be like
you know like maybe we're gonna be a
little bit more humble and like you know
like you know courteous to people but
like just like that to me was like so
disrespectful like
yelling at your guests
like for nothing really
i don't know like that just to me is
like something i just could never bring
myself to do just like if you're a guest
at my home like i'm gonna treat you with
a certain level of respect you know what
i mean
well
well that was during like when all that
stuff was going on so maybe if it was
you know if it happened again they'd do
it differently
i don't i don't know
when people are saying like i don't know
what they're they were saying like i
don't understand this weird like loyalty
that all the cat like they're like oh
you disrespected their platform like
they let you on i'm like
i met them like once like why on earth
would i have a loyalty to people that i
met one time
there's a heavy level of bullying that's
going on which is actually pretty
concerning because like like
yeah
people on youtube like they want to look
because they didn't have a good role
models growing up like you mentioned how
like you had like you know your dad is
like a big role model for you um i guess
i had more like my role model was like
like arnold schwarzenegger like you know
like
you know like people like who like
actually accomplish it in life right
like i never looked up to like youtubers
as role models
um
but i think that a lot of people they
just like they need a role model they
don't have anyone they like look at
someone who's a youtuber they're like oh
he's my role model and then they will
defend them to like death like that
person could literally be like i am
stealing money and i'll be like he never
said that he was stealing your money he
just said
only general you know maybe he's
stealing money from bad people so
they'll just defend them to like no end
um which is like pretty concerning
because you should never like fanboy or
fan girl it's really mostly men and boy
not hard about anyone well and in
pick-up and self-improvement you have
every incentive to lie
like
in what sense
um
like
you're gonna sell more stuff if you say
you get more girls
oh you're gonna sell more stuff if you
say your life is better than what it is
i'm not saying there's not like legit
people like i wouldn't have you on my
podcast if i didn't believe that you
were legit but it's just be cautious
with people on the internet because
it's easy to fake a facade like there's
even people that come up and talk about
that in like the rap industry like
they're selling a lifestyle it's the
same thing with like
anything when it comes to
self-improvement
yeah well that's true there's a lot of
there's like different levels of it
there's some people who will exaggerate
a little bit some people exaggerate a
lot there's some people outright why
uh there's different levels of it for
sure
go ahead
go ahead sorry i'm gonna say like i try
to keep it like
like i have yeah like
i'll never out lie or i'll never heavily
exaggerate i might like
change certain things to make the story
flow better like you know like i'm on my
sales page where i'm writing like my
story of like you know whatever how i
got good like i'll simplify it for like
to sound like to flow better i'll never
just like
you know deceive people into getting
sales but yeah i do feel like that's
kind of where i feel like most people
um because you you definitely can sell
more if you're willing to like collide
well i think they get like just like
this happened i think it comes out
eventually
like sooner or later like i don't think
you could have a 10-year career on the
internet if you're just faking all of it
rsd
actually i i don't know anything about
ours no i mean yeah it you know it does
i think that
version could definitely push the line
um so it was like enough time to caught
up with them um
yeah but it depends like you can
you can't get away with like
super insane level [ __ ] for a long
period of time we can get away with a
moderate level of [ __ ] for an
extended period of time so i don't know
i mean the whole industry is like pretty
fun
what do you think of mgt
or mgtow and better bachelor do you know
them
um monktao i thought was men going their
own way i didn't know that was a youtube
channel does he mean mgtow dictionary
if the question is what i think of mgtow
dictionary
is
uh i have mixed feelings about him i
think he's like um
like a very smart and witty guy um i
just agree with some of the beliefs he
has
uh especially like the hardcore
blackpill beliefs but he's an
interesting character um better bachelor
i don't really know i've heard of him i
haven't watched his content so i can't
comment
and what are the 30 of the things you
disagree with when with alpha male
strategy strategies and the 70 that you
agree with just like one or two yeah i
have a whole video on that on my channel
off top of my head um he says don't
confirm dates
which i think is super dumb so his whole
thing is like oh when you confirm a date
you seem like needy and then you give
the girl an excuse to flake so he
recommends just like showing up on the
date um or whatever or maybe like
texting a girl like five minutes
beforehand like hey i'll be there in
five minutes which i think is super dumb
because if you don't confirm with a girl
she's just gonna think that you forgot
or you're no longer interested in she's
gonna make other plans
um so i definitely disagree with that
um what's another one on top of my head
um
i it was it was a while since i made the
video but i have a whole video
completely dedicated to it
um do you want to get married and have
kids one day will your lifestyle change
at that point
um
i don't know
yeah that's like kind of like a cop-out
answer maybe but i really don't know
what i'm gonna want in 10 years so i'm
not ruling it out i might one day
actually get married and have kids or i
might not it just depends like what i'm
yeah i'm not completely ruling it out
but i'm not like striving for it either
i'm just kind of gonna go with how i
feel i definitely want to like really
grow the business first before i like i
get into any of that that's like a
requirement i have
how old are you i'm 31.
okay you actually look younger than that
thank you
31 yeah you have time especially as a
guy i feel like guys have like until
they're 50 and they really want to start
a family
yeah although i would i don't think i
would want to be like too old to be
having kids because then you're like
you're like 70 by the time the kid is
like you know a teenager and then like
you can't really like play with them and
[ __ ] so i don't think i would want to
have a kid past like a certain age
yeah
no i agree um
like i think 50 is a little too old but
you still could if you really wanted to
yeah versus women are like limited like
45 you can't at all in between like 35
and 45 there's like inherent risk
yeah and it just depends on like your
genetics too as a girl
do you think you're ever gonna have kids
oh yeah i will like as long as i can
find like you know someone that wants to
like do that with me
you'll have to baby me
um no i want like i think i want four
kids actually
okay i want i want them to be all boys
okay hear me out and then they'll be a
basketball team and my love for them
will be decided on how they play that
week and i will run all the plays
because they're going to be really tall
so what are you going to what are you
going to do if they're all girls
like barbies and like instagram and [ __ ]
none of them care about sports um
they're going to care about sports um
because my love for them will depend on
the world
they will be basketball players i if
they're girls i'll be disappointed
because there's not really a future you
know in women's sports like not much of
one anyways
um you know i mean like if you're really
good you might make an okay salary but
it's not like
i'm trying to get kids in the league you
know what i mean i just want some tall
gingers like dunking i'm just trying to
imagine because you're probably gonna
wind up with a guy who's like even
taller than you so like you're gonna be
with like a six foot guy and up but like
what is the likelihood of you having
like a short baby can like two six wood
plus people have like a five foot five
baby
i mean i'd be so disappointed um
no
just inject them with like human growth
hormone and [ __ ] like come on
my
dad's side isn't that tall because my
dad's 5-11 so like his sisters aren't
super tall my mom's also 5-11 and she's
like short in her family
so i think it i think it's like unlikely
but
who knows
i'd be so sad oh my gosh i'd be they'd
still be maybe just be point guards i
don't care
damn yeah i feel like it's like less
than like a five percent chance
yeah you never know you're kind of a
tougher spot because like you like i'm
assuming you don't want to go shorter
than you but like most guys are gonna be
shorter than you
yeah well i think
my position like as a female is like
almost like the worst position to date
in yeah because like as a girl you're
really not attracted to guys shorter
than you
um
i don't care if they're like my height
or it's close but and especially if you
make like good money like girls tend to
want like guys that make like more money
than them
um i don't think that's like the end all
be all for me but i think if you're like
successful as a girl and you
are tall i think that's like the hardest
position to be in in terms of like
attraction almost
i would agree with that for sure
like me personally i've never been
attracted to girls like even like i want
a girl who's like at least a few inches
shorter than me
um i'm not even like that tall like 511.
um so yeah i can imagine i was like a
tall girl like
there's some advantages but there's also
a lot like disadvantages because it's
like it rules out a lot of guys for you
well i think it's funny because
like
um
yeah i don't know i think it's it's
funny because i didn't realize only ten
percent or like fifteen percent of men
are over six foot
so that's like a very
what i don't know i thought it was like
maybe 30.
but yeah i guess but i've actually never
had a problem like i've had mostly like
like short guys be interested in me like
i'm just not interested in them
yeah i can see that bruh
but thank you so much for coming on the
podcast i really yeah it was fun for
sure
um
go subscribe to playing with fire um i
do think he has legit like pick up
advice
um i'm not just saying that because he's
here
um
like all the stuff i've seen from your
channel is like very practical and
reasonable and yeah like i think as a
girl a lot of it i would i think would
work on me
that would be much appreciated i do try
to keep it practical and uh reasonable
okay guys so go subscribe to him and
don't forget to scroll subscribe to my
channel as you guys know i'm moving to
england in a month trying to get my subs
up and i will talk to you guys next time
bye guys